ce qui donne masi qui donne qui dansent
marrakech et rabat en armant une frappe
à longueur d'année à la vie à toi c'est
moi qu'on a fait
management ou d'un des jeunes ont
pénétré dans l'hôtel quelques dizaines
de secondes heure on va prouver alors
vous avez fait quoi alors d'improviser
étoile sportive avec des gens de crever
ça fonctionne pas du tout chef jan pro
nintendo en sorte mais tous les matins
green island où j'allais dire non vous
avez les ordinateurs oh bien sûr
connaître un diamant non mais je besoin
de sang les jambes tout on regarde
assurance avec soin pour la garde
c'est parti c'est pas aussi simple ce
que tu pourrais
mais non
s'il te plaît [ __ ] c'est trop cool mon
gars de la pratique life je me souviens